Çeviri: Suleyman Cengiz
Gözden geçirme: Figen Ergürbüz
Hoş geldiniz hepiniz efendim.
(Alkışlar)
Arkaları da görebiliyorum böyle yapınca.
Başlamadan kısacık bir soru soracağım.
Kaçınızın bir hayali var?
Ama yani işte başarılı olacağım,
doktor olacağım, mimar olacağım,
şu olacağım bu olacağım değil.
Örneğin Klimanjaro Dağı'na tırmanacağım
Kafkas Parsı unvanını ben alacağım
gibi bir hayalden bahsediyorum.
Elinizi kaldırabilir misiniz lütfen?
Keşke herkesin eli kalkmış olsaydı.
Şimdi birkaç soru soracağım, yanıt
istemiyorum, sadece aklınızda kalsın.
Kekeme birisi tarihin gelmiş geçmiş en
büyük hatibi olarak nitelendirilebilir mi?
Hayır.
Peki, evi, maaşı, işi olmayan
idama mahkum birisi,
tüm rütbeleri sökülmüş bir asker
başkomutan, mareşal olabilir mi?
Gene bir soru olarak kalsın aklınızda.
Peki üçüncü soru:
Türkiye'de bir bilim programı
bir haber kanalında,
bir ulusal kanalda yapılabilir mi?
Üç sorunun yanıtı da evet.
Şimdi sizleri milattan önce hızlıca...
...milattan önce 106 yılına götürüyorum.
Romanın şöyle 50 km kadar dışında,
taşrası sayılabilecek bir yerde
bir çiftçinin, daha doğrusu
bir nohut üreticisinin oğlu.
Nohut cicer demek Latincede,
bahsettiğim isim Çiçero.
Çiçero kekeme.
Ama bugün Avrupa tarihini,
Avrupa edebiyatını yazan
bütün tarihçiler Çiçero'nun --
bakın çok önemli --
bir, sadece Latin dilinin değil,
tüm Avrupa dillerinin
gelmiş geçmiş en büyük icracısı
ve kullanıcısı olduğunu iddia ederler,
bir dilin kullanımına dair yeni şeyler
geliştirdiğini ifade ederler.
İkincisi, tarihin gelmiş geçmiş
en iyi hatibi olduğunu iddia ederler
ve üçüncüsü, Çiçero'nun
yine tarihin gelmiş geçmiş
en çok halk desteğine sahip
lideri olduğunu ifade ederler
İlginç gelişmeler, ilginç sözler
bunlar tabi ki hatırlatalım.
Oysa Çiçero kekemedir.
Ve hepinizin bildiğini düşünüyorum,
bilmeyenler için de hatırlatalım.
Önce avukat olur,
ondan sonra felsefeci olur.
Yunan felsefesinin önde gelen neredeyse
bütün yapıtlarını Latinceye kazandırır,
Roma dünyasına tanıtır.
Kendisi de bir felsefecidir.
Ama tüm bunların yanı sıra övündüğü
tek bir nokta vardır: Politikacı kariyeri.
Avukatlık yaptığında ipe gönderdiği de çok
olmuştur, ipten aldığı da çok olmuştur;
ama politikacılık kariyeriyle gurur duyar.
Nasıl duymasın ki!
Yaşadığı dönemi size kısaca hatırlatayım.
Muhakkak isimleri duymuşsunuzdur.
Jül Sezar, Kleopatra,
Marcus Antonius, devasa isimler.
Bunların hepsi büyük mareşaller,
çok soylu ailelerden geliyorlar,
çok zenginler, Çiçero'da hiçbiri yok.
Bir, orta halli bir çiftçi ailesinin oğlu.
Ama okuyor, kendisini geliştiriyor
Günlerce, aylarca deniz kıyısına gidiyor,
ağzına çakıl taşları dolduruyor,
o çakıl taşlarını tek tek denize tükürerek
çene kaslarını, ağız kaslarını,
dil kaslarını geliştiriyor.
Ağzında çakıl taşlarıyla
konuşarak konuşmayı öğreniyor
ve dünyanın bu güne kadar gelmiş geçmiş --
konsensüsler üzerinde --
en büyük hatibi oluyor.
Hatta öyle ki Cumhuriyetin
hamisi haline geliyor,
Jül Sezar'ın gerçekleştirdiği
darbenin ardından.
Biliyorsunuz hani o sen de mi Brütüs
lafının geçtiği yer Senato merdivenlerinde
Senatörlerin katıldığı
bir darbeyle Sezar öldürülür.
Brütüs --evlatlığı demek çok doğru değil,
ama çok yakın ilişkisi olduğu bir isim --
son darbeyi vurur, sen de mi Brütüs --
et tu, Brute lafının işte geldiği yer.
Hepimiz bunu biliriz, ama
bir sonraki lafı çok bilmeyiz.
Brütüs, Sezar'ın cesetinin başında --
Çiçero bu darbeye dahil değildir,
ama hepsi Çiçero'yu çok sever,
onun öğretilerini takip eder --
kanlı bıçağını havaya kaldırarak
ey Çiçero, şimdi sıra sende,
gel ve cumhuriyeti ayağa kaldır der
ve cumhuriyeti ayağa kaldırır.
Darbelerle uğraşır, efendime söyleyeyim,
Sezar grubunun, Sezaryen grubun
bir sürü komplosuyla uğraşır, temizler
ve sonuçta cumhuriyeti
yeniden ihya eder hakikaten.
Peki bir başka isimden bahsedelim.
Hiçbir şeyi olmayan bir mareşal,
bir asker, Gazi Mustafa Kemal
Atatürk'ten bahsediyoruz tabii ki.
Falih Rıfkı Atay'ın
Çankaya'sını okuyan var mıdır?
Hemen okuyun.
Hemen okumanızı çok tavsiye ediyorum.
Biz liderleri,
özellikle de kendi hayatımızı
ilgilendiren liderleri düşündüğümüzde
onlara tanrısal bir güç
atfedildiğini düşünürüz, değil mi?
Onlar bizden farklıdır,
onlar bizden ileridedirler,
onlar bambaşkadır, ilahi bir
dokunuş vardır onların üzerinde.
Hayır, Selanikli bir
yetimden bahsediyoruz.
Üstelik annesi daha sonra evlenmiştir,
evlendiği için annesiyle arası bozulmuştur
-- üvey babayı pek sevmez.
Yine Falih Rıfkı Atay'ın, en yakınımdaki
isimlerden biri olan Falih Rıfkı Atay'ın
1950'lilerin henüz başlarında
yazmaya cesaret edebildiği
birçok şey vardır o kitapta.
Örneğin Atatürk'ün
gençliğinde çok sıkılgan,
utangaç birisi olduğunu ifade ediyor.
Kalabalıkta çok fazla konuşamaz,
çok fazla kendisini ifade edemez
ve hatta -- içki zararlıdır, bunun
altını çizerek söyleyeyim ama--
sosyal ortamlarda biraz
sohbet edebilmek için
bir kadeh içkiye falan
ihtiyaç duyduğunu ifade eder --
Falih Rıfkı Atay'ın
Çankaya'sında yazılı bu.
Hatta şöyle söyleyelim,
o kadar kendisini geliştirmiştir ki,
o kadar ciddi biçimde geliştirmiştir ki
Kurtuluş Savaşı başlamadan önce,
bizim bugün Kurtuluş Savaşı
kahramanları olarak bildiğimiz isimler --
mesela İsmet Paşa, mesela Rauf Orbay --
öylesine ümitsiz durumdadırlar ki,
onlara yeniden ümit kazandırır
ve Kurutuluş Savaşı'nın çok önemli
aktörlerinden biri haline getirir.
O ümitsizliği anlatacak
bir cümle söyleyeyim mi size?
Çok farklı kaynaklarda var, örneğin
Kazım Karabekir'in hatıratını açın,
hemen ilk sayfalarında,
ilk bölümlerinde görürsünüz.
İsmet İnönü, yani ikinci
cumhurbaşkanı ülkenin,
ikinci adam dediği
Şevket Süreyya Aydemir'in.
Kazım Karabekir'e
ne der biliyor musunuz --
Kurtuluş Şavaşı henüz başlamadan,
Atatürk henüz Samsun'a çıkmadan önce.
Kazım --çok yakın arkadaşlar tabi--
bu işler böyle olmayacak,
gel biz vazgeçelim
bu askerlik sevdasından,
Silivri'de bir çiftlik alalım, orada
çiftçilik yapmaya başlayalım,
yapamayacağız der.
Benzer bir şekilde örneğin Rauf Orbay,
Kurtuluş Savaşı'nın daha
ilk adımlarının atıldığı günlerde,
yani heyecanlı bir arkadaş der
Amerikan Büyükelçiliği'nde
yapmış olduğu bir konuşmada,
bugün bir sürü pis işle uğraşıyor,
ama yarına ilişkin pek bir politik
kariyeri olacağını pek zannetmiyorum;
dolayısıyla biz konuşalım,
biz işleri yürütelim der.
Sonrasını hepimiz biliyoruz aslında.
Gelelim üçüncü sorunun yanıtına.
Türkiye'de bilim programı yapılabilir mi?
Yapılabiliyormuş, onu görmüş olduk.
Kendi üzerime burada herhangi bir pay
yüklemiyorum, öncelikle onu söyleyeyim.
Yükleyebileceğim tek bir pay varsa
buna cesaret etmiş olmam,
hayal kurmuş olmam.
Benim hayallerimden hakikaten birisiydi.
Amerikan televizyonlarında,
İngiliz televizyonlarında insanların
büyük bir medeni olgunluk içerisinde
içi boş olmayan, dinledikten sonra
bir tortu bırakan, hayatımızı etkileyen,
bizim bir yerden bir yere varmamızı
--hadi hepsini bir tarafa bırakıyorum--
kafamızda yeni soru işaretleri
yaratan, seviyesi yüksek,
entelektüel sohbet yapabileceği
bir program olsa, ah keşke olsa,
yıllarca bunun hayalini kurdum
Şimdi çok şükür o büyük lüksü yaşıyorum.
Dediğim gibi burada
bizim yaptığımız tek şey,
benim yaptığım üzerime
alabileceğim tek şey cesaret etmek.
Biz de yeni bir izleyici
kitlesi oluşturduk
ve kimsenin bilmediği bir şey ifade ettik,
zaten hazır olan sizler gibi
çok kıymetli insanlar,
gördüğü anda gereken değeri biçti
ve bizim programı izlemeye başladı
ve zaten ben de o sayede
karşınızda yer alabiliyorum.
Ama çok, çok, çok fazla
engel vardı önümüzde.
Bir kere ekip sıkıntımız vardı,
iki kişi yaptık biz bu programı.
Maddi sıkıntımız vardı, beş kuruş
paramız yoktu, tanıtım yapabilecek,
reklamımızı yapabilecek
bir mecramız söz konusu değildi.
Üçüncüsü, Türkiye'deki tartışma
kültürü çok kötü bir yere gelmişti.
Hakikaten çok kötü bir yere gelmişti.
Dolayısıyla bir programda altı
kişiyi, beş kişiyi bir araya getirip
sizin fikrinize katılmıyorum, bence mesele
böyledir dedirtebileceğimize inanmıyorduk.
Oysa çok yanıldık, çünkü dediğim gibi
bunda da bizim bir payımız yoktu.
Zaten bizim toplumumuzda, bizim
toplumuzda var olan bir melekeyi
biz sadece görünür hale getirmiş olduk.
Üçüncüsü, televizyon
programları, siyasi tartışmalar,
herkes siyasi yelpazede kendisine düşen
payı oynar, oranın amigoluğunu yapar.
Biz öyle bir şey yapmadık, politikadan
uzak durduk siyasetten uzak durduk.
Gerçekten insanların hayatına
dokunulacak işler var mıdır
diye düşündük, onları yapmaya çalıştık.
Ve gördük ki bir çok insandan
gelen mesajla birlikte
hayatlara dokunabiliyormuşuz demek.
Bu da benim hayallerimden bir tanesiydi
Tabi kendimi ne Çiçero ne de
Gazi Mustafa Kemal Atatürk gibi
dev bir isimle, devleşmiş bir isimle,
kendisini devleştirmiş
bir isimle karşılaştırmıyorum;
ama ille de ülke kurmanız gerekmiyor,
ille de cumhuriyeti
ihya etmeniz gerekmiyor.
Hayatınızda bir hedef koyup,
bir hayal kurup önce
arkasından bir hedef haline getirip onu
adım adım ona yaklaşabiliyorsunuz.
Hadi madem bunu söyledik,
yine Atatürk'ten bir örnek verelim.
Birçok röportajında da geçer:
Nasıl başarıyorsunuz, hedefinize nasıl
ulaşıyorsunuz siz Paşam diye sormuşlar.
Atatürk'ün verdiği yanıt çok kolay:
Hedefimi koyarım,
hedefe giden yola bakarım,
sonra o yoldaki engellerin
ne olduğunu bulmaya çalışırım.
O engelleri tek tek ortadan kaldırdığımda
iş zaten kendi kendisine yürür.
Hedefime ulaşabilirim, benim ekstradan
bir şey yapmama gerek kalmaz diyor.
Önemli bir yol haritası.
Ha bu arada konuşmanın
sonuna doğru geliyorum,
ben uzatmayacağım, buradaki süre sınırına
mümkün olduğunca uymaya çalışacağım.
Benim bir hayalim daha vardı.
Şöyle kalabalık bir salonda,
3-5 bin kişinin karşısında
müzik grubumla şarkı söyleyebilmek.
Müzik grubumu kurdum, kayıtlarımı yaptım
ve şimdi 3000 kişinin
yaklaşık karşısındayım.
Konuşmamı da öyle bitireceğim.
Var mısınız hep beraber?
(Alkışlar)
Güzel günler göreceğiz çocuklar
Motorları maviliklere süreceğiz
Çocuklar inanın, inanın çocuklar
Güzel günler göreceğiz, güneşli günler
Motorları maviliklere süreceğiz
Çocuklar inanın, inanın çocuklar
Güzel günler göreceğiz, güneşli günler
Motorları maviliklere süreceğiz
Hep beraber göreceğiz.
(Alkışlar)